[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire françois bayroux haut
commissaire au plan préconise pour
redresser la démographie française une
hausse de la natalité et l'immigration
il manque en effet 40000 à 50000
naissances par an dans notre pays pour
assurer le renouvellement des
générations et par la même occasion
payer nos retraites
le problème n'est pas seulement français
y touche toute l'europe continent
vieillissant où la natalité encore
plongé du fait du baby crash mondiale
provoquée par l'épidémie de vide en
chine où le taux de natalité taux plus
bas et le vieillissement de la
population nette augmentation il est
désormais permis au couple de faire un
troisième enfant d une politique de
limitation des naissances est plus
facile à faire respecter qu'une
politique d'incitation à faire des
enfants
et si on fait de moins en moins
d'enfants il faudra faire venir de plus
en plus d'immigrés pour compenser
d'autant plus qu'un certain nombre
d'écologistes inquiet du réchauffement
climatique voudrait que l'on arrête de
procréer alors pour en débattre nous
avons invité gérard françois dumont
géographes économistes démographes
professeur à la sorbonne président de
l'association population et avenir qui
édite la revue du même nom vous est
l'auteur de nombreux livres dont une
géographie des populations chez armand
colin
alors vous êtes plutôt du pour les bébés
ou pour les immigrés ben c'est simple il
faut d'une bonne solidarité entre les
générations les bébés on sait à quel âge
il arrive donc il concourt à la
solidarité entre les générations les
immigrés tout dépend quel type immigrés
donc cela ne veut rien dire de dire je
suis pour l'arrivée d'immigrés ça dépend
lesquels
antoine penot vous vous êtes l'auteur de
permis de procréer aux éditions albin
michel vous étiez venu en parler à sa
sortie dans cette émission et de futures
notre avenir de a à z qui est paru à la
fin de l'année dernière chez le même
éditeur vous vous êtes pour les bébés ou
pour les immigrés alors c'est pas du
tout le même éditeur mais c'est pas
vraiment le sujet si je voulais répondre
de manière caricaturale je vous dirais
que je suis plutôt pour les immigrés
mais en réalité et vous allez croire que
je botte en touche et à mon avis la
question n'a pas vraiment de sens parce
que faire des bébés ou avoir plus
d'immigrés c'est comme si on avait deux
leviers qu'on pouvait actionner
facilement alors que pas du tout c'est
des leviers qui sont totalement
dissymétrique je vais le dire de manière
le simple on ne peut pas faire plus de
bébés en revanche on peut faire moins de
bébés et en revanche
al'inverse on peut pas avoir moins
d'immigrés parce qu'il est très
difficile de contrôler l'entrée sur le
territoire et les renvoie dans les pays
d'origine
en revanche oui il est possible d'avoir
plus d'immigrés
donc cette dissymétrie elle rend la
question un peu bancal on va voir ça
julien d'amont vous vous êtes sociologue
professeur associé à sciences po vous
êtes l'auteur de nombreux livres sur les
sdf les bidonvilles où la sécurité
sociale les derniers sont les 100 mots
de la ville chez que ce lg la question
sdf aux puf
mais vous intéressait également à
l'effondrement démographique en vue en
europe vous verrez vous devez lui
consacrer un article très documenté dans
slate alors vous vous êtes plutôt pour
les bébés ou pour les immigrés ben je
répondrai sans voter en touche en posant
une autre question pourquoi faire si
c'est pour contribuer à l'amélioration
de la productivité au rééquilibrage des
comptes sociaux les immigrés c'est ce
qui est mieux à court terme
enfin à long terme je voterai pour les
bébés alors regardons d'abord la
situation française je les dis il
manquerait entre 40000 et 50000
naissances par an pour assurer le
renouvellement des générations
on est tombé
à vingt huit enfants par femme est-ce
que c'est grave
gérard françois dumont en fait
d'ailleurs figurez vous qu'on est tombé
en france métropolitaine en dessous de
1,8 enfants par femme d'après les
derniers chiffres et c'est pas là le
problème le problème effectivement c'est
que la france était dans une situation
relativement favorable en europe puisque
sa fécondité était plus élevé que celle
des auteurs pays européens et donc son
hiver démographique était relativement
faible par rapport à nos voisins
le problème dont qui se pose c'est qu'il
faut bien comprendre que des nouveaux
nés la venue de nouveaux nés a
automatiquement des effets sur une
société elle a des effets d'abord
économique dans la mesure où tout
simplement les enfants sont des
consommateurs donc à partir du moment où
vous avez moins d'enfants vous avez
moins de consommateurs et elle a des
effets surtout qualitatif dans la mesure
où effectivement une société qui
accueille des enfants est obligé de
faire des efforts pour accueillir ces
enfants
alors c'est vrai à l'échelle d'un couple
qui accueille un enfant supplémentaire
qui va modifier sa structure de
consommation qui doit modifier ses seuls
de vie qui va éventuellement se se
motiver pour essayer d'avoir des revenus
professionnels plus élevé pour
satisfaire aux besoins de cet enfant et
puis c'est vrai aussi à l'échelle d'une
commune qui lorsque sa population
scolaire ce maudit augmente
eh bien elle va être obligée là aussi de
répondre aux besoins de cette population
en réorganisant ses épaules en
organisant de l'offre en terme d'accueil
aussi dedans ou dans les associations
d'accueil évidemment pour les
équipements sportifs etc
donc en fait les ddc pas neutre
ça a un effet direct sur sur l'évolution
d'une économie alors après évidemment on
évoque toujours le problème de
financement des retraites etc qui est
vrai mais moi j'insiste surtout s'il est
sur l'aspect court terme ou en fait une
évolution de la natalité
tout de suite dé explique court terme
sur la société même si elle a aussi des
effets à moyen terme et notamment la
diminution de la population active à
terme autres effets à court terme de
l'arrivée d'un enfant c'est qui va
balancer à peu près 50 9 tonnes de co2
dans l'atmosphère
ça c'est un argument qu'elle vous êtes
sensibles antoine buéno ah oui je suis
très sensible et je suis très content de
vous l'entendre dire donc je vais
répondre précisément à votre question
est ce que c'est grave qu'on est con ne
parviennent pas en france à renouveler
les générations
alors je vais vous répondre de manière
très simple c'est embêtant pour pour la
france éventuellement embêtant parce que
ça encore ça se discute donc c'est
plutôt une pas très bonne nouvelle pour
la société française
en revanche c'est une excellente
nouvelle pour la planète
parce que de manière globale la
démographie humaine a un impact qui
aujourd'hui excèdent de très très loin
les capacités de support de notre
planète
parmi les gestes écologiques dans les
l'impact a été quantifié les gestes
individuels il ya plusieurs études qui
montrent que renoncer à avoir un enfant
améliore le bilan carbone de sa vie à un
point mais incommensurablement plus fort
que simplement ne pas prendre l'avion
être vegan ou ne pas avoir de voiture
donc l'enjeu écologique c'est un enjeu
vital alors que l'enjeu démographique de
décroissance de vieillissement de la
population
par exemple à l'échelle française est un
enjeu social c'est pas du tout sur le
même plan c'est pas les mêmes
conséquences
d'un côté on a un phénomène de société à
gérer et qu'on peut gérer et qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas que des effets négatifs
d'ailleurs monsieur dumont le dit il
faut voir ça de manière assez assez
assez globale ça a beaucoup d'impact
dans le vieillissement de la population
des positive des moins positif et c'est
donc d'un côté on a ça qu'on peut tout à
fait gérer
de l'autre côté on a une question de
survie de l'espèce et je le dis en
presque en mesurant mais moi je vais pas
vous faire l'article sur le
réchauffement climatique parce que je
crois que maintenant tout le monde en a
soupé est bien conscient des choses mais
nous sommes déjà largement trop nombreux
et les projections de l'onu
nous explique que demain nous serons 10
milliards en 2050
après-demain presque 12 milliards en
2100 et la population mondiale ne
commencera à décroître qu'à partir du
22e siècle c'est-à-dire beaucoup trop
haut et beaucoup trop tard par rapport à
la gravité de la situation
environnementale
alors les enfants se seraient à peu près
l'équivalent de en tonne de co2 un ce
serait l'équivalent de 24 voitures
annuel qui fonctionnerait toute l'année
donc chaque fois que d'un label ratio
voilà non
le rassemblent entre eux ne pas avoir de
voiture et ne pas avoir d'enfant c'est
un 24 voilà si on part du postulat canon
qu'une personne supplémentaire sur la
terre c'est un chômeur de plus dont
effectivement à ce moment là je suis
tout à fait d'accord il faut diminuer le
nombre de pôles heures le problème est
de savoir si ce nouveau né qui va naître
va être un âme un atout ou un handicap
pour l'humanité parce que ce nouveau né
qui va naître c'est peut-être lui qui
l'a réalisé des progrès techniques qui
vont permettre à l'humanité d'être mieux
respectueux de l'environnement est en
réalité on le voit bien parce que selon
les pays du monde et selon les
territoires
les émissions de co2 par habitant sont
extrêmement variés nous avons des pin's
est très élevé des pays où c'est plus
faibles et en fait tout dépend du
comportement des individus dans leur
respect de l'environnement
donc ce que l'on constate par exemple
c'est que vous avez des pays qui peuvent
être très peuplé avec une forte densité
de population comme la suisse dans la
densité de population est encore plus
élevé parce qu'il faudrait il faut
compter que les terres arabes faut pas
compter évidemment les territoires à
plus de 2000 mètres des alpes où les
suisses ne peuvent pas habiter or
justement sous cette contrainte
eh bien vous avez un pays qui est
beaucoup plus respectueux de
l'environnement de la france je vous
rappelle que la suisse a créé il ya 40
ans il ya trente ans par dont la taxe à
l'essieu c'est-à-dire a fait un effort
considérable pour encourager le fret
ferroviaire et décourager les camions
qu'à l'époque il y a trente ans on avait
un ministre de l'equipement cadet
considéré que les suisses avaient eux
tant de retard en réalité c'est eux qui
avaient raison donc si mais c'est
justement sous cette contrainte de
densité de population que la suisse a su
prendre des décisions beaucoup plus
respectueuse de l'environnement que la
france alors julien d'amont est-ce que
c'est grave en france le vieillissement
de la population
c'est problématique c'est pas forcément
grave je dirais sur la question quand
même de la survie de l'espèce je trouve
assez paradoxal de dire que pour que
l'espèce survivre il ne faut pas mettre
au monde d'enfants l'espèce en prendrait
quand même pour son grade
en un siècle disparaît très bien pour
répondre à votre question je trouve moi
qu'un monde sans enfant avec un monde
avec moins d'enfants est un monde triste
des villes sans enfant sont des villes
triste des femmes et des hommes qui ne
mettent pas au monde les enfants qui
correspondent à leur projet de couple
sont des couples et des parents qui ne
seront jamais véritablement par an
triste enfin je trouve que c'est pour le
dire avec un mot claire absolument
inhumain de vouloir toujours la
fécondité le désir de fécondité dernier
mot je trouve qu'on bascule souvent mon
dans des considérations écologistes à
certains égards très discutable mais
aussi immédiatement dans des
considérations sur les régimes de
retraite et les régimes de protection
sociale en disant ah bah oui bah quand
y'a pas assez d'enfants pourra pas payer
les retraites il suffit de réformer les
retraites il suffit de tichy d' assez
facile autour d une table face à une
caméra de le dire mais s'il fait de
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
cela dit quand vous dites c'est triste
un monde sans enfant brun aujourd'hui on
vit dans une société dans un pays sur un
continent où on a moins envie de faire
des enfants qu'avant que pour rester
guerre les gens j'ai l'impression
préfère ne pas avoir d'enfant
on les en empêche pas il ya eu la
politique de l'enfant unique en chine
pendant très très longtemps
enfin accès en 2004 ils sont passés deux
enfants aujourd'hui passé à 3 le
problème c'est que ça change rien les
gens ne font pas d'enfant et en france
comme l'a dit françois bayrou on peut
soit on assiste à la naissance soit il
va falloir trouver un autre moyen a lui
suggéré les immigrés on en reparlera
enfin le problème pour l'instant c'est
que les gens ne veulent pas faire
d'enfant c'est pas qu'on le leur
interdit va le faire des enfants et à
désir de fécondité qui est mesuré
historiquement par l'ined avec un désir
d'enfant qui est de presque 3 enfants
par femme et on est presque à deux
enfants par femme
même si on est en dessous de 1,8 donc il
ya toujours un désir d'enfant et qui
cocorico se réalise en france plus
qu'ailleurs parce que si la france voit
son nombre d'enfants baisser son taux de
fécondité baissé nous sommes toujours en
occident le pays où le taux de fécondité
est le moins dégradée donc non il ya
toujours un désir d'enfant
modulo des délires écologistes oui
antoine alors je vais je pas le prendre
pour moi concernant les délires
écologistes mais je crois que
l'intervenant précédent a vraiment pas
conscience de la réalité des choses la
situation est extrêmement grave et oui
je parle de survie par ailleurs ne vous
inquiétez pas il y aura encore des rires
d'enfants là on est en plein délire
on va bientôt être 10 milliards et on me
parle d'extinction de l'espèce non mais
c'est du délire il n'y a plus une
baleine
il ya plus un lion et toutes les espèces
autres que l'humanité sont en train de
crever et on parle de la survie de
l'espèce
je ne sais même pas de quoi on parle on
parle pas non plus de plus faire
d'enfants on parle de moins faire
d'enfant vous inquiétez pas on va être
10 milliards et sur les 10 milliards y
aura encore beaucoup beaucoup d'écoles
de rires d'enfants et de petits minocchi
eux joueront et qui font marcher
l'économie du jouet alors par ailleurs
le désir d'enfant en france ça c'est un
délire total parce qu on est le pays
dans lequel les politiques familiales
sont les plus développés c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
empêché par les difficultés sociales et
sociétales qui qui plombe la natalité de
certains pays par exemple comme l'italie
on a des crèches on a des systèmes de
garde d'enfants on a des allocations
familiales on a des des coefficients
familiaux etc
on a plein plein plein plein d'edge
crois que c'est la france le pays dans
lequel on aide le plus et donc on est si
vous me passez l'expression au tac et de
notre désir d'enfant c'est à dire que
l'espèce de flûte consistant à dire il
faudrait faire plus d'enfants en fait on
ne sait pas comment faire plus d'enfants
tout simplement parce que comme le
disait frédéric les gens ont les enfants
qui veulent bien avoir et que ça
correspond à une mutation sociologique
forte
ils ont le nombre d'enfants qui veulent
aujourd'hui ne sont pas empêché en
france d'avoir des enfants
en revanche effectivement si on rendait
les choses plus difficiles en faisant
moins de places en crèche par exemple ou
moins d'allocations familiales quoique à
mon avis les allocations familiales
n'entre pas en ligne de compte dans le
choix de faire un enfant oui l'a pas on
briderait le ce désir d'enfant enfin
aujourd'hui hop comme ça par un coup de
baguette magique ou par une loi qui
dirait je sais pas quoi on double
compris pour les allocations familiales
on aurait plus d'enfants en france de
deux bébés nationaux non c'est faux
mais moi je suis d'accord pour rien que
le lien est ténue entre la dépense de
politique louisiane ont la fécondité
d'accord maintenant je pense que votre
désir de vouloir réduire le nombre
d'enfants en france c'est dur étrange
qu'on souhaite de un nombre d'enfants
plus restreints dans les pays où la
transition démographique n'est toujours
pas passée où le nombre d'enfants par
femme est extrêmement problématique ne
serait ce que sur un plan sanitaire je
peux le comprendre mais ça concerne
l'afrique subsaharienne
ça concerne ni la seine saint denis la
vendée françois gérard françois dumont
oui je voudrais quand même revenir sur
le chiffre de 10 milliards en fait qui
est un chiffre qui effectivement souvent
évoqué n'envoie personne ne sait si un
jour il y aura 10 milliards d'habitants
sur terre
d'abord il faut savoir qu'avec la
pandémie code divise 19 et vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre introduction les
données démographiques ont été
fondamentalement modifiée dans le monde
et donc on n'est pas dupe sur la route
de 10 milliards avec les derniers
éléments que nous avons à disposition le
deuxièmement ce chiffre de 10 milliards
ne peut arriver que l'humanité capable
de les nourrir
etait-ce une humanité ne détruit pas son
environnement
parce que si effectivement pour arriver
à 10 milliards
si nous n'avons pas de suffisamment de
produits
agricole nous n'arriverons pas 10
milliards escomptés les gens pourront
pas courir
deuxièmement s'il ya eu des dégradations
de l'environnement tels et on n'ira pas
non plus à 10 milliards
parce qu'à ce moment là il y aura une
surmortalité surmortalité infantile
surmortalité des adultes
nous voyons par exemple dans certaines
régions de chine où les conditions de
l'environnement sont très dégradés et où
la pollution est très élevé eh bien vous
avez la mortalité infantile qui a
remonté
vous avez l'espérance de vie qui a
baissé et puis ça dépend aussi des
comportements
vous voyez très bien que l'espérance de
vie a diminué aux etats-unis face
notamment à l'importance de la
consommation de drogues également face à
l'importance de la vente et de l'obésité
est donc ce chiffre de 10 milliards pour
moi n'a pas de signification pour une
autre raison c'est qu'en réalité le
problème n'est pas de savoir si à 10
milliards d'habitants c'est savoir où
ils sont exactement sur terre prenons un
exemple supposons que nous arrivions à
10 milliards je reprends ce chiffre de
long terme
et supposons que ces 10 milliards
d'habitants on l'est concentre
uniquement aux états unis donc on enlève
tous les habitants de l'europe
tous les habitants de l'afrique tous les
habitants de l'asie tous les habitants
de l'amérique latine
tous les acteurs de l'australie bien sûr
aussi et on les met tous aux états unis
qu'elle sera à ce moment là la densité
des états unis eh bien ce sera une
densité inférieure à la densité actuelle
de la région ile de france
donc vous voyez comme comme pas tout
tout est relatif le second élément qu'il
faut préciser c'est la question des
politiques sa vie bien effectivement
lorsqu'on regarde les les politiques
familiales et les fécondité en europe
eh bien on constate une certaine
corrélation est assez bonne
c'est à dire que les pays qui ont le
plus de politique familiale sont ceux
qui ont les clés qu'on dit et les - abc
et ceux qui ont moins de politique
familiale sont ceux qui ont les
fécondité les plus basses comme l'italie
que vous avez cités tout à l'heure et
concernant la france on voit très bien
si on regarde sur plusieurs décennies
l'évolution de la technique et française
et puis on constate qu'à chaque fois
qu'on a eu des hausses ou des baisses de
la fécondité
ça a été soit à la suite de décisions
positives sur la
politique familiale soit la suite de
décisions négatives sur la politique
familiale
c'est ce qui m'avait permis de dire dès
2015 que la fécondité de la france
allait baisser
compte-tenu effectivement des décisions
de rabotage la politique familiale qui
ont été prises à ce moment là et c'est
bien ce qui s'est passé depuis
donc en fait il ne peut pas croire que
les politiques familiales nous serait
neutre toutes les politiques publiques
en des effets sur la vie des populations
il n'y a pas de neutralité donc prenons
un exemple très précis le gouvernement a
voulu réformer le congé parental en le
rendant beaucoup moins 1 favorable pour
les couples quel est le résultat bat le
résultat c'est qu'il ya beaucoup moins
de 2 de personnes qui ont pris le
système du col du congé parental que
ceci a engendré la baisse de la
fécondité qu'en revanche certes le
gouvernement économiser un milliard
compte tenu de sa réponse c'est quand
même assez d'accord avec gérard françois
dumont souhait de dire un petit mot
là-dessus mais je vous en prie je suis
fière de mon alors dans le cas d'espèce
il ya eu en effet une réforme de
l'indemnisation du congé parental qui
est moins favorable avec le gouvernement
hollande sur la même période il ya une
augmentation considérable du nombre de
crèches et les nombres de d'assistantes
maternelles qui potentiellement propose
des capacités d'accueil pour les jeunes
enfants
quand je dis considérable c'est que sur
une décennie on est passé à la louche de
50 % des enfants de 0 à 3 ans qui
pouvaient prétendre un accueil formelle
en dehors de la famille à 60 % quand
parallèlement en effet il y a eu
rabotage par modulation des allocations
familiales rabotage du quotient familial
et tripatouillages voilà c'est le mot
qui me vient à l'esprit pour le projet
le congé parental
ceci pour dire que je pense qu'en france
la fécondité reste à un niveau
relativement élevé entre autres choses
parce que nous avons un environnement en
pas l'écologie là qui est favorable aux
familles et les corrélations entre les
niveaux de fécondité et les politiques
familiales à mon avis peuvent se
discuter et moins se discute et
statistiquement que les corrélations
entre l'acceptation de nouvelles formes
familiales et je ne parle pas comme au
parentalité des débats mettent pleins de
gens dans la rue mais là où il ya le
plus au nombre
enfant où la fécondité est la plus
élevée c'est là où les enfants naissent
le plus en dehors du mariage
donc en gros il vaut mieux divorcer et
aisément et pouvoir organiser des
recompositions familiales pour qu'il y
ait des enfants
c'est dans les environnements où le
droit de la famille et le plus libéral
que et où les égalités les niveaux
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
sont les plus élevés il y a le plus
grand nombre de bd antoine penot ont le
droit de la famille sait où est la face
pour la société considère l'accueil de
l'enfant alors effectivement la
fécondité c'est un phénomène
plurifactoriels j'ai insisté sur
l'aspect politique familiale julien dame
en a tout à fait raison d'insister sur
la façon dont la société accepte
l'enfant et la force de la france c'est
que c'est un pays qui accueille les
enfants qui naissent dans le mariage ou
hors mariage alors que les pays du sud
de l'europe considèrent encore dans une
très forte proportion que l'enfant ne
doit n'est qu'après le mariage ce qui
est une des raisons de leur faible
fécondité en binôme ou alors pour
répondre à tous à matha à moi c'est que
compte tenu de la puissance de la
politique familiale française de sa
complétude si vous me passez
l'expression il semblerait que nous
soyons au plafond sociologique c'est à
dire que le désir d'enfant soit
parfaitement satisfaits dans notre pays
et que même s'ils ont multiplié les
aides on n'obtiendrait pas un gain
énorme et donc la question est-ce qu'il
faut des bébés ou des immigrés elle est
pas opérante puisqu'on ne peut pas
décider selon ma thèse selon moi si on
est au plafond sociologique d'avoir
comme ça du jour au lendemain par une
législation par exemple même par des
aides économiques plus de bébés
nationaux premièrement deuxièmement sur
les 10 milliards un chiffre en 1950
l'onu avait prévu qu'en l'an 2000 nous
serions 6 milliards c'est exactement ce
qui s'est produit c'est à dire qu'il est
très difficile de faire des
anticipations à peu près pour tout ce
qui concerne le monde sauf pour une
chose c'est la démographie est là le nu
a bien prévu qu'on serait 9 points 5
milliards en 2050 compte tenu de
du fonctionnement de ces anticipations
j'aurais plutôt confiance d'autant plus
qu' on a évoqué lakovic 19 qui va
changer totalement à la marge les choses
et c'est alors le dernier argument que
j'ai entendu qui est absolument
formidable c'est celui des gérard
françois dumont qui finalement va tout à
fait dans mon sens et qui me dit nous ne
serons pas finalement 10 milliards
puisque la crise environnementale est
telle que les gens vont crever comme des
mouches donc cqfd
il faut faire des enfants c'est pas
grave pour l'environnement puisque à la
fin ils crèveront tous à cause de
l'environnement
j'adore le raisonnement je préfère pas
les mettre au monde voyez plutôt que de
les voir mourir de famine de guerre
mondiale je ne sais quoi parce que les
risques vont être extrêmement important
dans un monde à + 2 ou 3 degrés et puis
là il ya une dernière chose qui a été
dit qu'ils étaient très intéressantes
c'est ça dépend de l'enfant qu'on fait
peut-être que votre enfant français ça
va être un génie qui va résoudre le
problème du réchauffement climatique
alors oui c'est tout à fait possible que
ce soit un génie mais en attendant votre
enfant quand il va naître il va pas
s'habiller en pagne et manger des
racines c'est à dire que votre enfant
français comme tous les français il va
émettre en moyenne 10 tonnes de co2 et
même si c'est un génie il pourra mettre
en oeuvre sa géniale invention qui va
nous sortir de l'ornière climatique
qu'au bout de 30 ou 40 ans d'études
assez poussée et dans l'intervalle et
bien le monde va continuer de se
réchauffer les adultes qu'ils fassent
des inventions également je voudrais
quand même corriger parce que ce que je
veux dire c'est que ces problèmes de
l'éducation à l'environnement
c'est à dire effectivement si on a des
sociétés où l'éducation environnement et
bien tu es donc les gens seront
respectueux de l'environnement ils
arriveront un livre maintenant
effectivement quand l'éducation
je parle et ça marche pas je pars ça
déclenche françois dumont ça marche pas
mais les plans vous avez évoqué le 6
milliards qui avait été prévu et est
finalement on est arrivé à 1,6 milliard
mais en réalité
d'abord il ya eu d'autres projections
qui étaient totalement différentes de
ceux ci willian et deuxièmement la
répartition de la population dans le
monde a pas du tout été celle qui avait
été prévu d'un par rapport à ces
différentes prospectives
or ce qui compte si vous voulez
localement
c'est c'est qu'une société s'organise
localement on va pas organiser de la
même façon une ville comme paris un
département de la lozère
la situation est totalement différente
au fait le respect de l'environnement
suppose des mises en oeuvre par et
simuler la transition écologique puisque
c'est celle qui font réussir
eh bien on ne réussit pas par les mêmes
mesures la transition écologique à paris
et en lozère il faut l'adapter aux
réalités et donc c'est en cela que c'est
extrêmement intéressant
donc je vous interromps de tous les deux
je vous donnerai la parole on fait juste
une pause on recommence juste après en
octobre 2020 l'exécutif européen a
présenté une directive relative à des
salaires minimaux adéquat dans l'union
européenne
objectif combattre la pauvreté chacun
des pays européens est face à une montée
des inégalités et à est limité très
violente de la pauvreté et l exclusion
on est en train de s'occuper d'un
salaire minimum alors que le problème
c'est que une fois déjà trouvé un moyen
pour faire baisser le chômage parce que
les chômeurs ils ont fait du du salaire
minimum ils n'ont pas de travail donc
ils n'ont pas de salaire on a un
problème de développement économique il
s'agit pas d'imposer un smic à des pays
qui n'ont pas les moyens tout simplement
d'y faire face
vous avez quand même pas mal d'étudiants
ont été faites
justement sur le smic en disant que le
tweak écartés du marché du travail les
gens peu qualifiés on peut se poser
aussi la question de savoir si
réellement c'est une bonne idée
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise c'est fiable
mais comment peuvent-ils mentir comme
des arracheurs de dents ce point
[Musique]
on prend ce débat avec gérald françois
dumont avec antoine buéno et julien
d'amont je voudrais qu'on revienne quand
même sur les conséquences de cette
baisse voire de cet effondrement
démographique qui nous guette en france
mais aussi en europe puisque la
situation semblait à peu près la même
sur tout le continent européen en tout
cas à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
tout ça est quand même n'est pas sans
conséquence un pays ou un continent qui
vieillit comme le nôtre ça n'est pas
sans conséquence ça joue sur sur
l'ambiance ça joue sur le moral ça joue
une population qui vieillit une
population qui investit de moins en
moins dans la recherche on l'a vu qui va
en revanche avoir des réflexes qui va
effrayer plus facilement qui va avoir
peur du nouveau
on est il suffit de remonter il ya un
siècle en 1900 alors les conséquences et
pas qu'à l'intérieur c'est aussi à
l'extérieur en 1900 les européens
c'était une un quart de l'humanité
aujourd'hui c'est en dessous de 10%
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont changé
entre temps ont colonisé le monde entier
on s'est beaucoup calmé pour cause de
l'afrique c'était 100 millions de gens
1900 aujourd'hui sont treize fois plus
nombreux
il serait beaucoup plus difficile à
coloniser qu'à l'époque et puis on était
à l'avant-garde des technologies à
l'avant-garde de la science à
l'avant-garde de l'économie on a vu
pendant le coc vide qu'on n'était plus
du tout en europe à l'avant-garde de
rien donc tout ça vous pensez vraiment
que ça n'a aucun rapport avec le
vieillissement
je viens du julien dames on s'y met
enfin c'est pas parce que l'europe n'est
pas à l'avant garde de tout qu'elle est
à l'arrière garde de tous enfin c'est
comme tout à l'heure ce qui était évoqué
pour dire qu'il fallait que on diminue
le nombre de crèches pour qu'il n'y ait
pas ces petits enfants qui naissent en
france parce que ce sont des gros
problèmes pour l'environnement
le sujet il est à mon avis
principalement si on doit trouver un
continent africain 1 et l'afrique nepad
en avance en quoi que ce soit
démocratiquement un scientifiquement
alors que en effet démographiquement
c'est là que nous avons les plus grandes
perspectives avec un doublement de cette
population de plus d'un milliard à 2
milliards à un horizon relativement
court
donc je réponds à votre question sur le
vieillissement incontestablement ceci
induit de nouveaux équilibres sociaux
induits des transformations radicales de
nos manières de vivre transformation nos
villes
tout ce que l'on veut est-ce que
nécessairement cela veut dire ne pas
prendre de risques
il ya des pays qui vieillissent bien
enfin moi je trouve que le japon j bien
accepte son vieillissement et c'est
pâques un vieillissement il accepte même
ce petit pays vous pourrez dire son
dépérissement puisqu'il devrait perdre
un tiers de sa population dans les 20 30
ans qui viennent mais ceci ne veut pas
dire que ça se passe mal totalement mal
au japon on peut bien venir
antoine buéno oui mais je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
julien damman l'exemple de l'afrique est
bon il n'y a pas de déterminisme
mécanique entre eux âge moyen de la
population et dynamisme progrès avance
économiques technologiques etc
je voudrais citer tout ce qui est mieux
quand la population vit parce qu'on a
tendance à penser à ce qui est moins
bien mais il ya aussi des choses qui
sont mieux par exemple le vieillissement
de la population sacrée démarche et vous
savez c'est tout ce qu'on appelle la
silver economy donc ça crée des
opportunités de croissance
qu'on parle de croissance une population
qui diminue démographiquement a beaucoup
moins de difficultés à faire de la
croissance parce que la patience elle
est calculée en fonction du nombre
d'habitants donc si vous produisez un
tout petit peu plus de richesses mais
qui a moins d'habitants bien ça fait
plus de richesse par habitant
de même le rééquilibrage des rapports de
force entre le capital et le travail
plus moi il ya deux travailleurs plus le
rapport de forces s'équilibrent en
faveur des travailleurs donc on inverse
un petit peu la vapeur il ya la question
de l'expérience et de la sagesse moi
j'aime bien les vieux puis comme je veux
j'en sais rien je préfère aussi plaider
leur cause
et puis lors la dernière question qui
est qui est sous jacente à tout ce dont
vous avez parlé c'est est ce qu'on est
moins dynamique est ce qu'on est est-ce
qu'on est plus peureux est-ce qu'on est
plus frileux quand on est quand on
avance en âge c'est pas sûr du tout moi
j'en côtoie des jeunes qui par exemple
pendant le coc vide et elle est plus
flipper de tous alors que les sondages
montrent et peut au contraire c'était
les plus de 60 ans qui étaient
favorables à l'abandon du masque à
donner plus de liberté et c'est
complètement contre ce qu'on peut vous
n'avez comme intuition en tête
donc je suis pas certain de tout ça et
vous général françois dumont d'abord je
crois il faut bien préciser qu'il y a
deux types de vieillissement de nature
totalement différente
il y a dû parce qu'on appelle le
vieillissement par le haut c'est à dire
en fait l'augmentation de l'espérance de
vie des personnes âgées et qui se
traduit effectivement par le fait qu'il
y à davantage de personnes âgées
puisqu'elle reste en vie et qu'il y a
aussi la possibilité pour elle veut dire
d'être plus active aussi vous voyez bien
le changement fondamental qui est
intervenu en matière d'âge à la retraite
je rappelle que quand la retraite a été
créée par bismarck en allemagne ce sont
les démographes qui lui ont dit bah
écoutez vous mettez ça 70 ans de 65 ans
ça vous coûtera rien du tout parce que à
cet âge là les gens sont tellement usé
aux visions travaillé toute la vie que
seule la retraite va pas durer longtemps
bon vous voyez aujourd'hui heureusement
on est dans une situation différente et
donc le vieillissement par le haut est
évidemment quelque chose absolument
positif et je vois pas qui peut qui
pourrait sans
l'indre même si il ya un effet de loupe
si vous voulez c'est à dire qu'on parle
beaucoup de la dépendance qui évidemment
est un phénomène qui existait dans toute
l'histoire de l'humanité n'est en
réalité le pourcentage des personnes
dépendantes n'augmentent pas et a même
tendance à diminuer même si le nombre
des personnes dépendant augmente compte
tenu de l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes âgées
donc ça c'est le vieillissement par le
haut d'un certain nombre d'effets et
puis l'autre celui dont nous parlons
avec les bébés c'est le vieillissement
par le bas c'est à dire le fait
effectivement que compte tenu d'une
fécondité plus basses les générations de
nouveaux nés sont moins nombreuses que
les générations précédentes ce qui va
entraîner par exemple une diminution de
la population active
alors quelle conséquence un peu à
l'échelle de l'europe prend 4,2
conséquences qui sont sont pas
contestables
la première effectivement c'est la
baisse de la population active que l'on
constate déjà dans un certain nombre de
pays puisque toutes choses égales par
ailleurs la création de richesses dans
un pays est proportionnelle aux
effectifs de la population active
prenons un exemple simple pourquoi la
belgique à un produit intérieur brut
s'il faut à moins élevé que celui de la
france pas tout simplement parce que
dans un coq nous sommes dans le même
système économique mais la belgique à
six fois moins de travailleurs qu'en
france donc les conséquences économiques
sont évidemment compréhensible mais
l'élément sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est ce sont surtout les
conséquences géopolitiques
c'est à dire que clairement qu'on le
veuille ou non la loi du nombre
ça existe c'est à dire que en fait les
capacités géopolitique d'un pays sont
dépendantes de l'importance de sa
population
à condition bien sûr qu'ils soient
qu'ils sachent utiliser l'importance de
sa population
donc c'est comme ça que la chine réussit
à se placer dans le monde parce qu'elle
est encore le pays le plus peuplé et
puis elle a surtout réussi à faire pour
les autres pays un immense marché de
consommateurs
compte tenu de sa réforme économique et
les autres pays n'ont pas compris que
derrière son ouverture économique bien
vu aussi là
hantée de mettre en place une puissance
géopolitique notamment par le fait comme
vous le savez que pour vendre des
produits en chine souvent vauvert des
transferts de technologie et donc la
chine a pu acquérir assez rapidement et
savoir faire technologique relativement
élevées donc nous sommes effectivement
dans cette situation où concernant
l'union européenne vous l'avait bien dit
tout à l'heure son toit démographie
gants dans le monde a diminué et voyez
bien que périodiquement par exemple le
fait que la france ait un droit de veto
au sein du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
est une question qui est remise en cause
compte tenu du fait que des pays plus
peuplés que la france et parfois
nettement plus peuplé que la france non
pas à ce droit de veto à l'organisation
des nations unies d'où les demandes
récurrentes qui ont été faites par des
pays comme le brésil ou comme l'inde et
le fait également que la france est
obligée de soutenir la demande de l'inde
d'avoir aussi une place de membre
permanent au conseil de sécurité
donc les conséquences géopolitiques
elles sont extrêmement importantes et
elles vont continuer bien sûr assez à
s'exercer au fil des décennies
pour illustrer ce que vous venez de dire
gérard françois dumont la chine en dix
ans a perdu aux mains dans le dos pour
sa population active a un passé de 70 %
de sa population totale qui travaillent
a aujourd'hui 63 % seulement en europe
on est passé de 67 à 64 % et selon les
projections se serait plus que 56 % de
la population européenne qui seraient
actives en 2050
effectivement si l'on vous écoute ça
risque d'être une catastrophe bien c'est
bien pour ça vous rappelez quand même
qu'en 2015
madame merkel sans demander l'avis
d'aucun autre chef d'état européen et
surtout sans l'un et sans informer aucun
autre chef d'état européen a décidé que
tous les personnes tous les immigrés qui
arriverait avec un passeport syrien
ils pouvaient entrer en allemagne bon
alors on a bien sûr expliqué la
dimension humanitaire de la décision de
madame merkel
on oublie toujours la dimension
économique fondamental c'est à dire que
l'allemagne depuis des années est un
pays dont la population active diminue
et très périodiquement l'équivalent du
medef allemand ne cesse de demander
l'ouverture migratoires du pays pour
avoir pour satisfaire ses de ses besoins
de nadal
donc nous voyons bien que l'allemagne à
ce qui est important aussi de noter
attendez que je n'oublie pas c'est
l'allemagne a compensé la baisse de
population active
non seulement par les immigrés comme des
immigrés du moyen-orient dont je viens
de parler mais aussi par des immigrés
grecque par des immigrés italiens par
des immigrés espagnols
donc en fait vous avez des pays comme la
grèce l'espagne l'italie ou même la
france qui ont payé l'éducation d'un
certain nombre de jeunes et ensuite ces
jeunes bas en allemagne et c'est
l'allemagne qui profitent de leur savoir
faire et il participe à la création de
richesses en allemagne donc c'est un peu
s'ils voulaient un pillage des
ressources humaines que l'allemagne a
fait en europe depuis la crise de 2008
et il faut savoir qu'en europe en 2005
ce canton risque de manquer de 37
millions de travailleurs alors je viens
dans mon ouïe moment j'ai une solution
bien plus simple à tout ça pardon je
n'entrerai pas question mais je pense
que sur la population active
plutôt que de passer par le recours à
l'immigration
il ya quelque chose que les populations
nationales n'aime pas singulièrement en
france c'est l'âge de départ à la
retraite si vous voulez que la
population active augmente
il suffit d'augmenter même sensiblement
l'âge de départ à la retraite vous avez
ainsi immédiatement beaucoup d'actifs en
plus alors ils sont âgés c'est
problématique il faut pas faire comme au
japon ou dans d'autres contrées où en
effet vous travaillez extrêmement tard
et les conditions difficiles mais la
france est le pays au monde où le temps
passé à la retraite est le plus long si
vous voulez augmenter la population
active a besoin de faire des bébés tout
de suite une sont réactifs que dans 20
ans pas besoin de prendre des immigrés
ceci va poser des problèmes de cohésion
sociale augmenter l'âge de départ à la
retraite je voulais dire un petit mot
aussi je profite d'avoir un tout petit
peu la parole au sujet de la france dans
le monde
parler de l'europe dans le monde la note
de françois bayrou contient des éléments
très intéressants là dessus la france
est un peu moins de 20% de la population
dans le monde
laisser le pays qui si les inerties
démographiques sont vraies va rapidement
devenir le premier pays de l'union
européenne en la matière nous allons
dépasser nos camarades allemands
je trouve que on est toujours très
critique à l'égard de notre propre
situation démographique
ceci alors que comme je l'évoquais tout
à l'heure nous sommes quand même le pays
en occident où le sujet de la
démographie est bien moins problématique
qu'ailleurs jeudi l'occident et si on se
concentre sur l'union européenne - les
britanniques nous sommes loin devant
tout le monde loin devant des pays qui
sont en voie de dépopulation c'est pas
l'hiver démographique expression qui
aime bien gérard françois dumont serment
la bérézina démographie en italie en
pologne en allemagne ça n'est absolument
pas le cas en france
et quand bien même on diminuerait le
nombre de places en crèche et le nombre
d'enfants ce qui évoque d'ailleurs à sa
manière la note de françois bayrou
ceci aurait un impact minime à l'horizon
d'une trentaine d'années donc cocorico
une nouvelle fois ça va pas si mal en
france antoine buéno oui donc pour
disons pour suivre tous qui sait tout ce
qui s'est dit et y répondre la
population effectivement comme le dit
monsieur dumont c'est l'un des attributs
de la puissance mais l'un des attributs
seulement aujourd'hui la première
puissance mondiale n'est pas du tout le
pays qui pèse le plus d'un point de vue
démographique
bon ça c'est une première chose ensuite
il faut bien voir que le vieillissement
de la population et la décroissance
ensuite démographique c'est d'ailleurs
dans des temps différents ça va
concerner toute l'humanité c'est à dire
que toute l'humanité va être logée à
cette enseigne mais à des moments
différents
et puis troisièmement est-ce que ça va
être une catastrophe pour nous par
exemple en france n'ont pas forcément je
veux dire parce que il ya au moins
quatre leviers qu'on peut actionner pour
y faire face dès aujourd'hui le premier
vous en avez parlé c'est le titre de
votre votre émission c'est l'immigration
avec l'exemple de l'allemagne
et c'est la question de l'immigration
choisie parce que il est très difficile
de diminuer le nombre d'immigrés qui
arrivent sur le territoire national en
revanche il est facile d'augmenter ce
nombre là et
de faciliter l'entrée et l'intégration
d'immigrés qui ont tel ou tel diplôme
alors l'allemagne nous a peut-être
pillés mais nous avons pillé toutes les
compétences par exemple médical des gens
qui étaient formés infirmières médecins
etc
par exemple au maghreb maintenant en
afrique subsaharienne il suffit de
fréquenter les hôpitaux pour voir que on
est de moins en moins soigné par des
français de souche donc nous organisons
aussi ce pillage l'immigration choisie
on peut l'augmenter on peut l'accélérer
pour régler notre problème
l'autre levier c'est le taux d'emploi
c'est-à-dire travailler plus plus
longtemps dans la semaine par donc avant
moins de vacances commencé sa vie active
plutôt effectivement la terminer plus
tard en partant à la retraite plus tard
troisième mode de deux troisième
solution type de solution c'est
augmenter la productivité du travail
grâce aux nouvelles technologies
et ça c'est pareil c'est une dynamique
qui est en marche et qui va absolument
révolutionner l'ensemble de notre outil
de production je pense au numérique
notamment là dès aujourd'hui et dans les
décennies qui viennent et puis la
dernière le dernier levier et ça c'est
pareil c'est monsieur du 2 mai c c'est
julien d'amour qui en a parlé c'est la
réforme du système de protection sociale
alors il a évoqué le recul de l'âge de
la retraite moi aussi je les dis un
instant mais pourquoi pas aussi des
systèmes par capitalisation
dire qu'on a entre les mains a pas mal
de levier qui nous permettent de faire
face à ça et de faire face à quelque
chose qui que tout le monde de toute
façon va devoir affronter un moment ou à
un autre sans histoire mais je voudrais
pas avoir l'air cynique mais imaginons
2054 milliard et demi de dévier tic 2
milliards de dhs africain et nous qui
serions chez pas 700 800 millions pour
c'est vraiment qu'ils vont pas venir
chez nous mais vous êtes naïfs nous si
on est entré en afrique c'est parce
qu'ils n'étaient que 100 millions et
qu'on était très nombreux et qu'en plus
on avait la supériorité technologique
mais l'abattement la technologie nous
ont rattrapés
ils vont pas nous laisser à quelques
centaines de millions dans cette dans
cette région tellement riche forcément
un moment la tentation sera d'y venir
et si nécessaire par la force ça s'est
toujours produit comme ça dans toutes
les époques
non là sauf que non gérard françois
dumont
non la preuve que non maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est le cas on a souvent
une grosse question qui était la
question de l'immigration choisie
et c'est vrai que si l'immigration
choisie ça constitue pour l'europe a
pillé les ressources humaines les
meilleurs qui sont utiles au
développement de l'afrique
c'est absolument dramatique pour le
développement de l'afrique je prends un
exemple sainte sous prétexte que
malheureusement la méconnaissance des
données démographiques a conduit des
gouvernements précédents à mettre en
place le fameux numerus clausus qui
limitait le nombre de médecins en france
le résultat c'est que par exemple depuis
la pandémie on a délivré plein de visas
à des médecins d'une à gré pour qu'ils
viennent en france parce qu'on manquait
de médecins comme si le maghreb lui même
n'avait pas besoin de ces médecins donc
ça je pense que c'est quelque chose dont
il faut prendre conscience parce que
piller les ressources humaines des pays
qui en ont besoin ce n'est pas une bonne
chose
le deuxième élément c'est que l'afrique
en réalité ça ne veut rien dire du tout
incite à dire que selon les pays de
l'afrique 1 eh bien nous allons avoir
des trajectoires
déjà nous avons des trajectoires
démographiques économiques extrêmement
différente selon les pays
et il en résulte des effets en termes de
migration très différents prenons
l'exemple de la côte d'ivoire la côte
d'ivoire donc comme d'autres pays
d'afrique est indépendante en 1960 tant
que la côte d'ivoire est bien gouverné
sous le président houphouët boigny
elle connaît un très bon développement
économique et du coup les ivoiriens ne
cherche pas aller ailleurs pour savoir
si l'herbe est plus verte parce qu'en
réalité la très grande majorité de la
population de ce monde souhaite vivre et
travailler au pays
la meilleure preuve c'est que plus 96 %
des habitants de cette planète habite
dans le pays où ils sont nés
donc vous voyez que la migration s'est
totalement minoritaires par rapport à
l'importance du nombre d'habitants sur
terre
donc je reviens à ma côte d'ivoire
pendant 40 ans ce pays n'est absolument
pas un pays d
ration de départ est au contraire c'est
un pays d'immigration
c'est à dire que compte tenu de son
excellent développement économique eh
bien ils attirent de la main d'or
d'autres pays africains moins bien
gouverner et ils attirent ces personnes
ont tenu de son taux de croissance
économique
malheureusement au début du xxème siècle
dans les années 2000 et bien un conflit
civil se déclenche en côte d'ivoire ça
veut dire que la gouvernance qui est
excellente malheureusement devient
extrêmement mauvaise que la situation se
détériore que tout cela se traduit aussi
par une case dans le système sanitaire
avec une augmentation des taux de
mortalité est à cette période là eh bien
on voit du coup les ivoiriens fassent
une situation de détérioration de leur
pays qu'ils se mettent à migrer vers la
france certains d'entre eux alors
qu'avant il n'y avait jamais dit
d'immigrants ivoiriens en france
donc vous voyez que tout dépend des
trajectoires démographiques et personne
ne peut prévoir à l'avancé si tel ou tel
pays d'afrique va réussir ou non un
meilleur développement parce que je
crois que bien sûr on peut avoir des
inquiétudes sur l'afrique comme on peut
en avoir ce pour l'europe mais il ya
aussi en afrique une société civile qui
dans certains pays est extrêmement
créative
je vous rappelle que quand par exemple
dans les innovations unis un pays comme
le kenya est parvenu à des innovations
numériques qu'aucun autre pays dans le
monde n'avait été capable d'imaginer
donc il n'ya pas fatalement un sous
développement en afrique et il y a des
potentiels de développement qui existe
et qui tue et qui se réalise le vrai
problème c'est les pays qui sont à
sécurité ou bien quand vous avez les
dictatures les pires avec des dirigeants
qui gouvernent particulièrement mal mais
personne ne peut savoir comment les
choses vont évoluer et la meilleure
preuve c'est que en fait dans la
migration africaine
on a plus d'immigrants africains kinnig
à l'intérieur de l'afrique que de
migrants qui migrent pour quitter
l'afrique
mais prenez un pays comme le zimbabwe il
a des richesses incommensurables
malheureusement depuis son indépendance
subi une mauvaise gouvernance mais bon
on peut que espérer que enfin ce pays
trouve des dirigeants qui lui
permettront d'utiliser le potentiel
extraordinaire qu'il a sachant qu'il
faut rappeler aussi que l'afrique
même avec sa croissance démographique
que vous a rappelé tout alain reste un
pays à la très faible densité de
population
or il y a des problèmes soulevés de
masse critique c'est à dire que vous
avez un certain nombre d'équipements qui
ne devienne rentable que s'il ya un
certain nombre de consommateurs et donc
c'est pour ça que vous avez un certain
nombre de territoires africains qui
deviennent intéressants et la meilleure
preuve que les territoires africains
sont intéressants c'est ce que fait la
chine en afrique
vous voyez que la chine investit dans
tous les pays africains
c'est ça c'est tout l'occasion de très
étonnant c'est à dire qu'on pourrait
penser que la chine investit en afrique
dans les pays d'hôtel peut tirer le plus
avantage donc dans les pays qui ont des
ressources remarquables ou dans des pays
qui représentent un potentiel très élevé
de consommateurs eh bien pas du tout la
chine elle a décidé d'investir dans tous
les pays d'afrique sans en oublier aucun
quel que soit le nombre d'habitants qui
règne ça veut dire que la chine est bien
consciente qu'il ya du potentiel partout
en afrique
même si la concrétisation de ce
potentiel ellle effectivement la qualité
de la gouvernance notamment antoine
buéno oui on est on était sur le
paradigme de frédéric des invasions
barbares
apparemment il n'ya pas de deux réalités
mécanique de système de vases
communicants faisant que quand il ya
très peu de personnes d'un côté et
beaucoup de personnes de l'autre et bien
les seconds se déverse chez les premiers
et c'est c'est ce qu'a dit gérard
françois dumont en fait on a envie de
rester juste rester chez soi
fondamentalement on veut rester chez soi
et quand on part on le fait pas de
gaieté de coeur on le fait parce qu on y
est contraint et donc cette question des
nouvelles invasions barbares
à mon sens vous allez dire que je suis
môme monomaniaque mais peut-être mais
elle dépend du réchauffement climatique
parce que les choses ont été assez bien
modélisés si les choses continuent sur
leur lancée et aujourd'hui on ne voit
pas comment il pourrait en être
autrement
autour des années 2050 à 2070 les
températures mondiales devraient avoir
augmenté d'un facteur de 2 à 3 degrés
par rapport à l'ère préindustrielle ça
donne 20% de la planète c'est à dire
toute la bande équatoriale et et autour
en fait donc donc une grosse partie de
l'afrique toute la zone tropicale qui
devient dans les années 50 2050 à 2070
régie par un climat saharien c'est à
dire 35 degrés de température moyenne
aujourd'hui les climats saharien c'est 0
8% de la planète saas fee 15 à 20% de la
planète et ça concernerait 3 5 milliards
de personnes alors delage revient sur la
question de la répartition de la
population
donc c'est 3,5 milliards de personnes
entre 2050 à 2070 qui se retrouve sous
un climat ça rien dans des conditions
que j'ignore
qu'est ce qu'elles font est-ce qu'elle
reste là est-ce qu'elle crève sur place
ou est-ce qu'elle essaye de venir
la parole est à julia d'amont pour
terminer cette émission elle se termine
en une minute trente alors c'est avoue
julien on va très bien la question vous
posiez était celle de savoir si les
pressions démographiques allait conduire
un déversement de l'afrique sur l'europe
eh bien oui va donc il n'ya pas de
déversement d'ile-de-france sur la
lozère
donc il ya un argument démographique
l'argument climatique je pense que
l'argument essentiel c'est l'argument
économique est là on ne peut qu'être
pessimiste
la crise du coc vide a un impact sur la
pauvreté par en france immédiatement
mais dans le monde
prise à la hausse singulièrement en
afrique subsaharienne de l'extrême
pauvreté ce que l'on regarde pas ce sont
des migrations économiques
d'abord et c'est ça que les
problématiques à gérer oui que ce soit
bien clair c'est pas pour moi c'est pas
les barbares c'est la pression
démographique c'est à dire qu'en général
quand on est très très nombreux ont fait
peu de cas des voisins qui sont beaucoup
moins nombreux en tout cas dans
l'histoire ça c'est plutôt passé comme
ça et ça s'est toujours passé comme ça
tant que les blancs étaient les plus
nombreux les plus forts donc j'imagine
que les autres pourraient faire pareil
elle heurte aux je remercie tous les
trois d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]